[موسيقى]
اخذوا دائما ان الرحله ناقصه اذا كانت
وسيله المواصلات ليست القطار
رحله التويتر من كالكا
فالمزيج بين صوت عجلات القطار ودفئ مشروبي
مع المناظر المتنوعه التي اراها من نافذته
مصحوبه بالموسيقى ياخذ الرحلات بين المدن
دائما في مكان اخر
يتميز اليوم بان بطل رحلتي هو القطار وليس
اي قطار فانا ساخذكم في رحله عبر اله زمن
داخل قطار تراثي بين مدينتي كلكا وشمل
الهنديتين قطار هما لاين كوين او ملكه
الهيمالايا في القرن التاسع عشر بدت فكره
مد خط سكه حديديه بين المدينتين مستحيله
ولكن قبل المهندسون التحدي ليتم ربط شيمله
العاصمه الصيفيه للهند وقت الحكم
البريطاني ببقيه شبكات السكك الحديديه
الهنديه
هذه السكه الحديديه التي تمر داخل سلسله
جباله مالايا كانت تحتوي وقت بنائها على
اعلى جسر متعدد الاقواس واطول نفق في
العالم
[موسيقى]
كما تم بناء 107 انفاق و 864 جسرا يعبر
القطار من خلالها قرابه 97 كيلومترا من
مدينه كالكا ينتهي الخط في مدينه شمله
بارتفاع
قطار هيمالايا كوين ضمن مجموعه من قطارات
الالعاب الهنديه وهي قطرات تسير بسرعه
بطيئه مقارنه بسرعه القطار التقليدي
لتمنحك تجربه رؤيه المدن بشكل كامل من
اعلى الجبال
[موسيقى]
الرحله مدتها ست ساعات ولكنها مرت علي
كدقائق فتاره نمر فوق غابه ارى فيها
اشجارا مختلفه الاشكال والانواع وتاره ارى
السيارات باحجام صغيره جدا من اعلى وهي
تمر وسط الشوارع وتاره اشاهد البيوت
الملونه والتصميمات المبهره للمباني
التراثيه ولكن اجمل مشهد هو غروب الشمس
وتحول السماء لدرجات الوان خاطفه هي رحله
لا تنسى لدرجه انني مازلت ارى مشاهدها
كلما اغمضت عيني لصباح العربيه ندى حجازي
الهند